- [Interviewer] You're the
first person I've talked to.
I've heard this many times,
but tell me about what
happens when you do this drug.
- I mean--
- Crystal meth.
- Whenever you do it, man,
it's like you can fuck forever,
I ain't gonna lie.
I mean, it's like, non-stop.
We can fuck for like,
from 7:00 pm to 7:00 am
and just be like, happy-go-lucky,
still full of energy,
going, running hard.
Not even stopping to smoke a cigarette.
It's like, just smoke a
cigarette while we're at it.
And you've seen my old
lady, she's beautiful.
I mean, who wouldn't wanna
go, you know what I mean?
So I mean, yeah.
- All right, Lee.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Lee,
where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm originally from right
here in West Virginia, Layland.
I was born and raised.
Ever since I was born, I've
been on Layland Mountain.
I really never moved off.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your family.
You had a--
- My mom, she's a, my stepdad,
he's the preacher at the church.
He passed away just not too long ago.
My mom, she runs the Dane
East Community Building
out there where we live.
She's kinda,
kinda into the community with everybody.
- [Interviewer] So kind
of a religious family.
- Yeah, I never followed
into it, but like, they was.
My mom, she's all about
it, and my stepdad,
he was all about it.
But I kinda was the, like,
never followed into it.
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- It was hit and miss.
I was kinda on my own from
like, I'd say 17 and up.
I just kinda did my own thing.
I kinda went out, left
mom, and went and hung out
with my buddies, and did everything else.
And then after I found
out how rough it was,
I kinda went back to my
grandma's house, man.
I got an RV up there, I've
lived and I've moved in it.
Been doing things from there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
Appalachia is a tough life
for a young man, right?
- Yes, sir.
- Finding work?
- Yeah, you got that right.
There ain't nothing
around here to be doing.
If you ain't logging and you ain't doing
some kind of power or welding
or something like that,
there's nothing really for you.
I mean, it's kinda, it's a slow thing.
- [Interviewer] The coal
mines have dried up?
- Yeah, there ain't nobody
doing no coal mining, hardly.
- [Interviewer] How far
did you go in school?
- I went all the way up to the 11th grade
and my baby mama, she got
pregnant with my little boy,
and I dropped out, 'cause I
had to go try to figure out
something to kinda support
everybody else with.
I went from that, I went
over to working at the
sawmill over here in Beckley.
I worked there for, I'd
say, almost three years.
Went from that to working
at the turkey farms
over in Lewisburg, I
worked there at Aviagen for
almost, I'd say three years there.
And,
from there on, I mean,
I've kinda just went into
working for myself and
working for a guy doing
mobile detail.
- [Interviewer] Now, how do
you support yourself today?
- I'm doing landscaping.
I do a lot of landscaping.
I got a vacuum you drag
behind your lawnmower
and you go, it sucks up
all the leaves, acorns,
and everything else out of people's yards,
and I go over to the rich
part of the neighborhood
and I drag it around behind my lawnmower,
and I do a couple of yards,
and I can make pretty money doing that.
- [Interviewer] That's
great that you're working.
Are drugs a part of your life?
- They have been, yeah.
I was pretty well strung
out, I was big on the ice.
I got into heroin for a little bit,
but here recently, I've
kinda got straightened out
a little bit, I've been
in the suboxone program
and it's been doing me really,
really good, actually.
- That's great.
That's great.
And what age were you when
you started with drugs?
- I was, I'd say I was probably 14.
- [Interviewer] And
drugs are a big deal for
everyone out here.
- Yeah, it's everybody.
I mean, anybody you run
into has either done 'em
or is doing 'em.
- Like the people you
went to school with, how
many of them got into drugs?
- Actually, most of the people,
I mean, a lot of the people
I went to school with
are really dead, I mean,
a lot of people died
from heroin, man.
Heroin's dropped everybody.
It's crazy how many people--
- Is it the heroin
or the fentanyl and the heroin?
- The fentanyl, yeah.
The fentanyl, it's dropping everybody.
I was just, I think it was yesterday,
I found out my good buddy, John Parker,
he was, he just died from it.
They found him dead,
actually, at his house.
- [Interviewer] And that's
happened many times?
- Yeah, it's crazy how
often it happens, really.
- [Interviewer] What keeps
you here in Appalachia?
- I just, that's a good
question, to be honest.
I mean, I don't really know
why I stay.
- There's so few opportunities
and so many reasons to leave.
- I think it's just that
my family's here, and
I just, I'm relentless
to run off and leave 'em.
I mean, my grandma,
she needs me right now.
I stay up on the mountain
with her all the time,
and she's got diabetes and she's got the,
where she can't, something with her mind
where she can't remember,
she leaves the stove on.
I'm just paranoid if I actually
was to get up and leave her,
if she wouldn't leave the
stove on, burn the house down
or something like that,
you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] And you've
got a nice girlfriend.
- Yeah, and I got a beautiful old lady.
Yeah, that's a fact.
But if I was to leave,
she'd leave with me.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you
and Sam should probably
think about what you could
do other than staying here,
especially if she gets her kid back.
- Yeah, no doubt.
- [Interviewer] Have you traveled?
Have you been to other
parts of the country?
- I haven't been to other
parts of the country.
I've been out of the state.
I've been to like, North
Carolina and I've been
to South Carolina.
Myrtle Beach, Maryland.
Nothing major, not too far off.
- [Interviewer] What are
the best things about living
out here?
Just give me some good things.
It's beautiful.
- I mean, it is.
It's beautiful, and you got wildlife.
And where I live at, man, I
live so far back in the country,
there's really not nobody else.
We don't live on top of each other like
out there in the city, everybody lives
right dead on top of each other.
Where I live at, my
closest neighbor's like,
half a mile up the road,
you know what I mean?
- How many acres do you have?
- My family owns like, 114.
It's on the top of the mountain.
It's actually in the middle of
the New River National Forest.
The only people that
own anything around us
is the Parks Service,
the park owns everything
that my family don't own.
So we're back there, we
can pretty much almost
gate it off to where only our
family can get back there.
But really, right now, it's
open 'cause people wanna
go back there and hunt Parks Service.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's
spectacularly beautiful--
- Yes, that's a fact.
- Around here.
Some of the most beautiful
land in the country.
- Yeah, I mean, if you've
been up here to Grandview,
right above where y'all are at right now,
and you go up there and
you can go to Turkey Spur
and you can look over.
If you look off of Turkey
Spur, straight across,
and you look over onto the mountain,
you're actually looking at the mountain
that my family owns over there.
- [Interviewer] What kind of
wildlife do you have here?
- We got bears, we got, they
say there ain't panthers,
but there is panthers, big cats.
We got coyotes, we got
bobcats, we've got rabbits.
I mean, we got rattlesnakes,
and we got copperheads.
It's, you name it.
I've seen a little bit of
everything around here,
to be honest.
- And deer, elk,
stuff like that?
- Yeah, we got the deer.
They say we got elk, I
haven't seen any elk.
But they say they released
elk, but I haven't seen any.
But where we live at, the
Parks Service is so bad about
catching all these nuisance bears
over here in the city limits,
and they gotta take 'em
and release 'em somewhere,
so they bring 'em over
there where we live at,
'cause we're in the middle of nowhere,
and they release 'em, and then
they become a nuisance to us,
and they're up there in our trash
and everything else in the nighttime.
You should see 'em, the other night,
whenever this big ole, something
was out there in the field.
I couldn't tell you exactly what it was,
but all of the sudden, we
was laying there sleeping,
and then all of the sudden,
there was this screaming,
it was crazy screaming, I
was like, "what is that?"
It woke me up, it was screaming loud.
I was like, "what is that?"
And it was something
out there got attacked
by something in the yard,
right beside the house.
It was so close it scared
the shit out of both of us.
(chuckling) It was crazy.
- Yeah, you're out in
the wild here.
What do you think got you
into this situation you're in,
with addiction and all that?
Do you think it was the environment?
Was it something in your childhood?
Was it--
- I think it was,
I think the main thing was, man,
'cause there wasn't nothing else to do.
- Yeah, I hear that a lot.
- 'Cause I mean, like,
there really ain't nothing
to keep you, I mean, like,
you get high, it passes time.
That's really, I mean,
I can't say that there's
too many other reasons, other than,
yeah, after I did it a couple
times, I liked the high,
and it kinda just kept it rolling.
Whenever I got into ice, I
didn't get addicted to ice.
I got addicted to the sex that
me and my old lady had on ice.
That's what was addictive.
It wasn't the ice that done it for me,
it was the seven, eight
hours, non-stop, going at it,
doing that is what got
me strung out on ice.
And that was the only time, like,
I'd go get it, and I knew
exactly what time it was
when I got home, you know what I mean?
So-- (chuckling)
- [Interviewer] You're the
first person I've talked to.
I've heard this many times,
but tell me about what happens
when you do this drug.
- I mean--
- Crystal meth.
- Whenever you do it, man,
it's like you can fuck forever.
I ain't gonna lie, I
mean, it's like, non-stop.
We can fuck for like,
from 7:00 pm to 7:00 am,
and just be happy-go-lucky,
still full of energy,
going, running hard.
I mean, not even stopping
to smoke a cigarette.
It's like, you just smoke a
cigarette while we're at it.
And you've seen my old
lady, she's beautiful.
I mean, who wouldn't wanna
go, you know what I mean?
So I mean, yeah.
I guess, she was part of
my addiction. (chuckling)
- [Interviewer] And you'll
stay up for how many days?
- I'm bad at, I crash at three days.
Three days, I'm out, it's over with.
A lot of people, they can stay,
Sam, she can stay up a lot longer than me,
but three days, I'm laying down.
I can do a big ole shot
of it and I'm still,
I'm laying down regardless,
I'm falling out.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, but
some people stay up for--
- Yeah, some people, they get,
I've heard of people been
up a week, and two weeks,
and I'm like, I don't even
know how they're doing it.
They're talking about shadow
people walking by 'em and stuff
and I'm like, "yeah, you
need to lay down, bub.
"You been up too long."
- [Interviewer] It's a crazy drug.
- Yes, it is.
Has people outside with flashlights,
3:00 or 4:00 in the morning,
just looking around outside,
and it's like, man, you
know the neighbor's high.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
What's your biggest fear?
- [Lee] Man, my biggest
fear is losing my family,
to be honest.
I think that's my biggest fear, really.
- You mean your parents?
- Not so much my parents.
My little girl, Sam, they're
mainly my family, really.
It comes down to it, my
grandma, my old lady, and Sam,
that's, my baby, that's my family.
I don't really include
my mom because, I mean,
I love my mom, don't get
me wrong, but I mean, like,
when it comes down to
absolute people I gotta have,
it's my old lady and my grandma,
'cause I worry about
my grandma so much that
I gotta keep her around me.
- Right.
What's the most important
lesson you've learned?
How old are you?
- I'm 30, yeah.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned?
- [Lee] (sighs) The most
important lesson I've learned
would probably have to be, stop,
it'd definitely have to
be stop choosing drugs
over family, I mean, for real.
'Cause I fucked my
family over so many times
for drugs, it's retarded.
And they've took me back
every time, so yeah.
- [Interviewer] What's
the worst kind of stuff
you would do?
- [Lee] Steal money out of her purse.
I've overdrafted her bank account.
- Your own mom?
- Huh?
- Your mom?
- My grandma.
- Your grandmother?
- Yeah, I've done it
to my grandmother.
And my mom, I stole her pistols,
sold the pistols for the dope.
Stole her cars on numerous occasions.
- [Interviewer] It's
not that you have these
terrible ethics, it's that
the drug makes you so crazy
that you'll do it.
- Yeah, so it's like, man,
if I--
- 'Cause you're not
that kind of, you're
not that kind of person.
- I mean, I may yeah, back in
the day, I may have been like,
"yeah, I'ma steal Mom's
truck and go run around
"for a little bit," but
I mean, I wasn't out
doing nothing crazy, but whenever
you're on that drugs, man,
you're like, "man, I
gotta go get this dope.
"If I don't go get this
dope, I'ma feel like shit,
"and I ain't feeling like shit today."
So you're like "fuck it, I'm
grabbing the keys and I'm out."
Regardless, whether she
knows you're doing it or not,
you're still doing it--
- Your morals go
out the window.
- Yeah, it's just like,
it's tough shit, I'm leaving. (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] Have you done prison time?
- No, I ain't never had to do prison,
but I've been in regional numerous times.
- Jail.
- Yeah, Southern Regional,
back here, right behind us.
- [Interviewer] Right,
yeah, we're next to it.
- Yeah, I've been there
on domestic battery,
domestic assault, destruction of property,
brandishing a weapon,
possession of narcotics.
You name it, I've been there.
I've been there about 15 times altogether.
It's all over idiotic, stupid stuff like,
stuff I shouldn't have never
even been doing to begin with.
- But drugs was the--
- Yeah.
- Was behind it all?
- Yeah, and then,
I mean, I started smoking
pot, but the pot kinda just,
the pot got to a point
where I just wasn't,
that wasn't what I wanted to do anymore.
And then, somebody's like,
"hey man, you like uppers?"
And I'm like, "what's an upper?"
He's like, "try some of this."
So I tried it and, it really
didn't do too much for me,
so I really didn't care much about it.
But then, me and Sam, she
wanted me to shoot it,
and I was like, "all right,
well, I'll let you do it."
I was like, "don't mess me up."
So I stuck my arm out
and she shot me with it,
and it brought me to life.
I was like, fully wound
up, I could run a mile
in a heartbeat, you know what I mean?
It was like it was nothing.
I was like, "hell yeah, I like that."
And then from that minute
on, it went into sex,
and like I told you,
that's what got me on it, really.
- [Interviewer] What's
helped you the most,
in terms of getting your life straight?
- Suboxone.
Suboxone's helped us out a lot.
That, and the fact that me
and her are on the same page
about getting her daughter back.
'Cause we're both pushing
for the same thing,
and we know if we fuck up, that both of us
are gonna fuck up, it ain't
just one of us fucking up.
If I fuck up, she fucks up.
So, we can't afford for it.
If it goes a bit south, it's
gonna go all the way south,
so we can't have it, so
we're just trying to ride
the straight and narrow to
get her little girl back.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
All right, Lee.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with me, man.
- I appreciate y'all, man.
- I wish you the best of luck.
- Yep.
- Thanks.